what we know about this couple is they
do put a lot of time and thought
into names i'm sure they've probably got
a very good idea
of what they're going to call their
little girl and i think many people are
expecting that
diana is going to be one of
her names i absolutely think that they
will want to
include diana as perhaps one of the
names
for their little girl maybe not as her
first name but i'm sure it's um i'm sure
it's
very high up on the list in terms of a
second christian name and i think that's
quite simply because
it would be for harry a wonderful way to
pay tribute to his mother
of course the cambridges gave charlotte
diana as a middle name
i don't think that precludes harry and
megan from doing exactly the same thing
i think
it's very likely to be chosen as a
middle name
megan is going to take some maternity
leave she didn't have much maternity
leave last time around she was really
busy
launching a clothing collection for
smart work she was
putting the finishing touches to her
vogue issue so i think she worked
incredibly hard during her first
pregnancy and didn't take much maternity
leave but i'm told
second time round she's actually going
to make a point of taking some time out
enjoying this time and prince harry's
also going to take his paternity leave
too
you know he's a very much a modern dad
and he's entitled to that time
he's going to take that time i think
there's always the hope that a new baby
will help to heal any roots they're
obviously a source of
absolute joy and you know william and
kate will be
incredibly excited to be welcoming and a
niece into the family
the first girl for harry and megan
everyone hopes that
by the time this little girl arrives
there will have been more conversations
and they will be in a better place and
of course
harry's due to come over in july for the
unveiling of the diana statue
so i think there are opportunities
for a better relationship between the
brothers and i think we've seen the
start of that
this weekend at the funeral
[Music]
you